jared was with us in West Virginia hi
Jared how are you I'm good these are you
better than I deserve what's up well I
have a car loan well as the truck loan
actually and it it's due to be paid off
at the end of the year if I continue on
with my regular monthly payment and like
my question is is if I should I pay it
off as quickly as possible and
potentially take a hit to my credit
score or should I wait until the end of
the year why do you care about your
critical creating say that um well
because I'm going to be getting married
soon and nothing around here can really
work with the mortgage without a credit
score I guess and lenders around here
and so I'm trying to load of crap that
is an absolute lie I mean you have no
lenders in freaking West Virginia that
do loans without a credit score now a
lot of them don't but I mean if you have
no credit score you can find somebody do
manual on writing get in touch with
church no mortgage you know no dude you
get out of debt you get your stupid
truck paid off and that's the best way
you set yourself up to be a good husband
good father going forward a good man and
we're gonna we're gonna be debt-free a
hundred percent no debt and if that
drops your credit score away and then of
course you cut you get rid of all your
debt your credit score disappears and
guess what you're gonna you know think
about how much money and interest you're
going to pay from now until Christmas to
babysit this false measure of financial
winning called a credit score your your
writing banks checks to have a number
that doesn't mean anything except to you
and a mortgage company just ridiculous
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the
bribe button to get the latest content
and check out these other great clips
from the show
[Music]